A sign of hope for Rahaf Mohammed al-Qunun.
These pictures show the young Saudi woman
leaving the airport in Bangkok, together with
officials from the UN refugee agency.
The UNHCR will assess whether she can be granted
refugee status, protecting her from deportation.
This marks a pause in a tense stand-off that
began on Saturday.
Al-Qunun arrived from Kuwait, where she was
staying with her family.
She was stopped at immigration.
She says her passport was taken from her,
and officials tried to send her back to Kuwait.
The 18-year-old then barricaded herself an
airport hotel room.
She drew attention to her plight on social
media, quickly gathering tens of thousands
of followers.
She said she feared for life, after her family
threatened her for renouncing Islam and cutting
her hair.
I'm not leaving my room until I see UNHCR.
I want asylum.
The Thai authorities then seemed to perform
a dramatic about-face, allowing a top UN official
to see her."We strongly advocated with the
Thai government and we received reassurances
that pending the completion of
the assessment
and any decision, she will not be sent back.
Today, the UNHCR representative is personally
here.
He has told me that he will take no more than
five days from now to give her asylum status
and
send
her on to a third country.
Al-Qunun now says she feels safe - despite
the arrival in the Thailand of
her father, who's a senior Saudi
government official.
Her
case has
once again brought international attention
to the kingdom, and the
obstacles
that women face there.